So Donald Trump did more than a dozen rallies
over the last few days. He's going crazy, going
11 a.m. to 11 p.m., doing rallies in the
dark, in the cold and the heat in the wind,
complaining about all of the weather at
every single one of these. We've learned
that these rallies are not without negative
effect. We've seen old folks get hypothermic
after being left at the rallies with no busses
to take them back to their cars. We've seen
folks get heat stroke as they start just spraying
water onto crowds in the extreme heat and sun.
Stanford study, which I will talk about, has found
that at least 700 people have died of Corona virus
thanks to Donald Trump's rallies. And it is all
about feeding his ego. If you are delusional or
whacked enough to even go to one of these rallies
during a pandemic, you're voting for Trump. He's
not convincing anybody. He's feeding his ego and
just some of the most insane things from the last
couple of days here. I can't cover it all. It
wouldn't be healthy to expose you to all of it.
But I'm going to play a few clips for you from the
different rallies. Trump here actually saying out
loud what his philosophy has been, which is
whatever Obama did, I will do the opposite.
Frankly, we just said, what did Obama do?
And I heard and you know what I did? I did
the opposite. I said, why did Obama do? And
then I did the opposite. That don't work.
Now, there's one thing that's missing there,
which is everything Obama did, he will undo
unless it's something he wants credit for, in
which case Trump will just claim he did it. Obama
protected preexisting conditions with Obamacare.
Oh, I protected preexisting conditions. Or I will.
What Obama did. Veterans choice. We did
veterans choice. Just say I did it. That's
the piece that was missing there. Trump
then continuing to glorify mob violence,
the surrounding of a Joe Biden bus and the
sideswiping of a staff vehicle. Trump loves it.
They had the thing with these really,
I would say very good people. They were riding
along the highway and you had sloppy Joes Bush.
So they escorted the bus and the radical
left said, oh, what a horrible thing
that is to escort the bus.
They don't tell you about it.
And Tifa that go around burning down
your cities, Democrat run only Democrat,
they don't talk about that, boppin people over
the head, killing people, extremely dangerous.
And we did an entire segment on that, so I
won't rehash it here. Then Donald Trump now
at a different rally. Donald Trump says, you know,
if Biden wins, we're not going to have anything.
Biden's going to he's been saying Biden will take
away electricity and indoor heating and cooling.
Now he has another list of
things Joe Biden will take away.
The Biden lockdown will mean no
school, no graduation, no weddings,
no Thanksgiving or Christmas.
No Easter, no Fourth of July.
No future for American, yes. Other than
that, he's doing quite a good job, right?
The reality is all of those things have happened
under Trump due to his mishandling of coronavirus.
Remember, guys, in March when Trump said, let's
do two weeks, two weeks of washing hands and then
we're going to reopen on Easter? It's going to
be amazing. It's Trump's mishandling that led to
this. It's a level of projection that in this this
close to the end of the campaign is just beyond
words. It's an authoritarian nightmare as well.
Donald Trump during one of his Korona rallies
over the weekend, not accepting that there will
be a peaceful transition of power if he loses.
And now they say, well, you
respect the decision of the voters
and will that be a friendly transition? First of
all, there's not going to be a transition within.
But then you say then you say, well, let me
ask you four years ago. Was there a friendly
transition? There was spying on my campaign
before even one. And what was worse was they
were spying on my campaign. After I won to
overthrow the president of the United States.
OK. Which is called treason, which
is called treason. And let's see what
the hell happened. I don't know why it
took so long, but it takes a long time.
Trump still will not say there will be a
transition. We now know, thanks to the report from
Axios at the top of the show, that the Trump plan
is in any scenario other than a Biden blowout.
Donald Trump will step up to a podium and declare
victory tomorrow night. And instead here he's
saying, you know, the real problems are the crimes
committed by Barack Obama, which, of course,
he still can't actually enumerate. We've slid
into authoritarianism. It's happened slowly over
four years. If Trump had started with this four
years ago, it would have been wow. But just like
we've been warning about normalization, it's
a little bit. A little bit. A little bit. And
now Trump regularly calls for the imprisonment of
his political enemies of Barack Obama. Joe Biden,
Hillary. And it makes news. But it is not the
unilateral outrage, the unanimous outrage that
it should be. We've all become desensitized to
it to some degree. Continuing, Donald Trump then
fabricated a meeting, which he then said was
a phone call with prime minister from Japan,
Shinzo Abe. The call never happened. People just
shrug. It's not even remarkable that Trump is now
making up phone calls. That didn't happen.
And you will eviscerate your auto industry.
It will be terrible. We can't do it. You
know, we've worked very hard to bring it back.
I've met with Prime Minister Obbie
of Japan. Great guy since retired.
He had a problem with health and. But
who. Fantastic man. And I said, no,
Shinzo, you have to send plans to Michigan. You
have to send plants to the United States. And
he said, no, no, no, I can do that. That
is a private decision. I said, Ginzler,
you're a powerful man. I'm sure you can do it. No,
no, no. I said you have to do it, Shinta, because
you're making too many cars, sending them here. We
want to make the United States. You have to do it.
This is what I can. The next day, they announced
there were five companies moving to Michigan and.
Japan. Japan is a great guy, that one.
Not only did that phone call never happened,
five companies that make cars didn't move into
Michigan either. It is all made up. Saturday
night, Donald Trump was in Pennsylvania. He
again floated this idea of Obama and Biden
committed crimes. The crowd chants, lock them
up. We still don't know what are the crimes?
Big tech. You look at what's been happening
lately, right? You look at the media where they
refuse to cover one of the biggest scandals. No.
But the biggest scandal is we caught them spying
on our campaign. Right. We caught them trying to
overthrow a duly elected, commonly known as me,
president of the United States.
Let's see what happens. Let's see what happens.
Very dishonest, Fi. You're right. Well,
not here right now. There are a lot of
people that call that treason, OK?
That's treason. And see what happens.
The people for law and order and due process.
Right, say lock people up who haven't even been
accused of a crime. Trump still struggling with a
lot of words. Minneapolis continues to evade him.
And then Portland, we want to go into Portland
so badly, take out the anarchists who would take
us about 25 minutes. You saw what
happened in Minneapolis, you know,
after a week and a half. They could have called.
They could have called a little quicker, like
not the only instance, you know, maybe just avoid
saying Minneapolis if you can't say it one more.
And don't forget, they've done a terrible job in
Minnesota where they left Minneapolis burned down.
And then here is Donald Trump saying ridiculously
that under Joe Biden I mentioned this,
you won't have heating in the winter. You
won't have air conditioning in the summer.
Biden has vowed to abolish the entire U.S. oil
industry. No fracking, no mining, no natural gas,
no heating in the winter, no air conditioning
in the summer, no electricity during peak hours.
Do his followers believe that? I read
an interesting piece over the weekend
catching up on my reading, as it were. That
suggests even Trump's followers don't literally
believe when Trump says things like there will
be no heating and cooling under Joe Biden.
But they are okay with it because they just write
it off as this is how politics works. Hyperbole
and lies, which is problematic because it
normalizes it, which is the exact opposite
of what we need. It should be ostracized,
not normalized. And then just to wrap up
the insanity, at an earlier daytime rally
in Newtown, Pennsylvania. Donald Trump,
just after we set a record of 100000 Corona
virus cases in a single 24 hour period,
Donald Trump repeats that. We are rounding
the turn and just doing great on the virus.
We're ready. We'll have that and we will have
it. But even if you didn't do so and I say
drives them crazy, we're rounding the time.
We're rounding that turn around, they.
And our economy went down less
than any economy anywhere in
the world. And it went up faster by far.
You know, they keep hearing about Europe,
Europe, Europe. They're not doing nearly as well.
Seniors will be first in line for the vaccine and
the vaccine will be free because it's not their
fault. It was China's fault. China did this.
So we have to make sure we have to. I'm
not saying it's going to happen, but
we can make it happen. We have to be at the end
of these rallies. Trump will do a few rallies
today. Trump may do a few rallies later this
week while the votes are still being counted.
We must make sure that by the end of this
week, these rallies are over forever.
We we don't have a choice. It's it's a
desperate, desperate situation. We'll have
more clips and coverage on our Instagram page
at David Pakman show for a much needed break
from the politics. How about coffee?
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman
for my slo mo espresso shot from this
morning. The politics still matter. But
just for like a 15 second break, you can find
that on my Instagram The David Pakman Show.